all right boys lock and load
so what are we dealing with here gun
runners no dealers
it's two women who are counterfeiting
coupons
this feels like a lot you don't think
we're coming in a little hot here balls
totals 138 55 cents is it it's like a
thousand coupons
your trophy yo yo yo
it's time to save with jojo is it hot in
here
or is it just me yes you mom
we have a mountain of death is this the
best we're ever gonna do
how come i'm so broke the system has set
us up to fail
you know who gets rewarded people who
don't follow the rules
it's time we start bending them a little
where did you get these
when you send these companies a
complaint they send you a coupon for
free stuff
all of these free coupons come from one
factory it's like robinhood
we gotta steal these coupons and sell
them to families who
really need them that's money in the
fence
[Music]
prevention officer thousands of these
coupons are getting mailed out
all over the country we need boots on
the ground asap
[Music]
they said that they were sending the fbi
what do you do you carry mail around or
something
that would be a mailman they carry the
mill i carry a gun
we are investigating a counterfeit
coupon ring
costing companies tens of millions of
dollars
we need someone who's had experience
with this sort of thing we've got to
spread the [ __ ] out i'm talking bank
accounts credit cards mustache house and
aliases could you say it all again and
like much slower
and do you have like a pad just to write
it down no get out
okay we don't wing it but we got oh we
got it you got to let me in on this
thing
who's the girl earl i think it's pretty
clear that earl doesn't know
call a sketch artist call a sketch
artist
who do you think she is kaiser soj
coupons aren't about what you buy it's
about the feeling again
they call it the coupon high supposedly
it's better than intimacy with another
person
that's so i've been told sorry i have
you not used a coupon or have you not
had sex
what happened
the website is way too easy to trace
back to you is there anything
else i should know about think so no
well
yo yo yo it's time to save with jojo i
mean
how could they trace it it back to you
yeah my face is right on it
you